تبي تمويل تبي اسعار تنافسيه صار هنا
الشركه تجي للبنك ما تجيني عشان والله
البطاقه اليوم بس اليوم اختلف الوضع اليوم
لا اليوم تبي حلول الماليه شامله ابي انا
اقدر اروح اخذ منك قرض بس اروح لواحد
يعطيني الخدمات هذه افضل هل انت ودك كبنك
انه عملك يكون موجود في اكثر من بنك لانك
انت خدماتك ما تقدم لا طبعا
[موسيقى]
يلا حيهم استضفنا سابقا في البودكاست عده
شركات تقريبا ماليه مثل تمارا وتابي
وغيرها بس ما قد استضفنا احد من البنوك مع
انهم يلعبون دور مهم في هالقطاع فاستضفنا
اليوم الاخ نايف الحربيه الرئيس التنفيذي
لتقدي المعلومات في البنك العربي اللي
مؤخرا صار اسمه ام بي عشان يساعدنا نشوف
قطاع التقنيه الماليه من وجهه نظرهم نتكلم
مثلا عن طبيعه العلاقه بين البنوك
والشركات التقنيه الماليه وعن المنافسه
اللي صايره حاليا بين بعض البنوك والشركات
الناشئه في تقديم نفس الخدمات وش اللي
يخليهم كبنك يقررون انهم يستثمرون مثلا في
شركه ناشئه او ينافسونها وعندهم عاد تجربه
في الاستثمار مع شركه ناشئه بنسولف عنها
وش الشركه الناشئه هذه ولا ايش تستثمروا
فيها وكيف يستفيدوا منها وما الى ذلك
نتكلم ايضا عن السبب اللي خلاهم البنك
المفضل لشركات التقنيه الماليه سواء
كخدمات او جوده الخدمه كثير شركات اقترحوا
انه استضيفهم وليش كانوا حريصين على
المصرفيه المفتوحه اللي تتيح لشركات
التقنيه الماليه انها تحصل على بيانات
حسابات العملاء مع ان اغلب الملوك كانوا
ضد انهم يطيحون الخدمه اساسا الى ما جاء
المركزي وفرض هالشيء وبنخدم نقاشنا بنقاش
عن القطاع البنكي وش الفرص اللي ما حد
اخدمها الى الان من شركات التقنيه الماليه
وكيف بتغير القطاع مع دخول شركات التقنيه
ماليه جديده وبنوك رقميه جديده والتشريعات
جديده مثلا مثل موضوع المصرفي المفتوحه
وغيرها اترككم الان مع الحلقه حياك الله
عبد العزيز هلا والله حياك الله ان شاء
الله انت اول وظيفه لك في البنك
يعني انا اقولها للشباب اللي عندنا
حسب الواحد حسب الفرص اللي قاعده تصير له
في في حياه العمليه بياخذ قرارات بس في
عندي ثلاثه اشياء انا دائما اتاكد منها
طول فتره حياتي الوظيفيه واحاول انقلها
حتى الى الزملاء معي تكون موجوده عندهم
دائما اذا انت في مكان يقدم لك
يقدم لك قيمه مضافه لك وانت نفسك تقدم
قيمه مضافه للمكان هذا هذا الشيء المهمه
جدا يجي الشيء الثالث هو الجانب المادي
اذا المكان قاعد يقدم يعطيك
الفاليو الصحيحه لك مرور لسه احيانا ممكن
تكون اقل او اكثر بشوي بس ما هي بشيء كبير
ما في ما في حاجه الى التغيير هذا شيء
مرتبطين من الجيل السابق اللي يقعدون في
وظيفه الفتره طويله جدا انا عن نفسي ترى
ما اطول
يمكن زي متوسط
وكنت اقدر اعطي برضو المكان المقاول
فاحسنه اقدر اطول معه
صحيح هي ريكورد ما كنت اتوقع اني بقعد 19
سنه بس زي ما قلت لك يعني الواحد ما يدري
وين وين ال ال الكارير حق او المجال
الوظيفي حقه يمشي فيه الحمد لله يعني على
المستوى الشخصي
بشكل كبير يعني مب جدا يعني يمكن اذا انا
بتذكر اني بديت تكنيكل سبورت ما دعم فني
دعم فني ازور الفروع اصلح الاجهزه ركب
طابعات واليوم انا اقود
القطاع التقني في البنك العربي بشكل كامل
تدرجت في السلم الوظيفي وهذا شيء يعطيك
يعني يعطيك استمراريه في المكان اللي انت
فيه طالما انت تشوف انك انت ممكن توصل في
يوم او قاعد تتعلم اشياء تضيف للسيره
الذاتيه حقتك وبنفس الوقت زي ما قلت
الجانب المادي مهم ولكنه مو بكل شيء ولكن
المهم طالما انت تحس انك انت يدفع لك
راتبك اللي انت راضي عنه
اعتقد انه كافي في انك تستمر في المكان
اللي انت موجود طبعا اذا حصلت فرصه تقدم
لك حاجه افضل ما يمنع انك انت تروح معها
اللي حصل خلال فتره ااا يعني فتره الحياتي
الوظيفيه اني انا مرتين يمكن استقلت كان
في فرص افضل والبنك تمسك فيني
وكان برضه هذا يعني يعني لشيء كثير ان
الاداره متمسكه فيني ان البنك يشوف لي
مستقبل عنده واستمريت معهم والحمد لله
يعني راضي كل الرضا
عن التقاعد ما ندري ايش يصير وبعيد تونا
عن التقاعد عشان ما تكبرني بس
ولكن ما ندري وانا ما ندري ايش المستقبل
فيه كل الامور مفتوحه ولكن المكان جدا
يعني جميل يعتبر بيتي الثاني
قضيت فيه فتره جدا رائعه
ويعني وليد فيه ذكريات واكون له كل
التقدير والاحترام ولكل زملائي سواء
الحاليين او السابقين يعني لهم مكان كبيره
ولا مره جدا
كبير انا ما اخفيك سابقا ال ال الصوره
النمطيه بالنسبه للبنك العربي ما كان يعني
كفرت كشركه ما كان شيء
كيف اقدر اقولها بدون ما يعني اسيل البنك
بس بالنسبه لي كان احد البنوك الجانبيه
اللي يعني ما كانت دائما في الواجهه
بالصوره يمكن مرتبطه مع المتقاعدين اكثر
شيء
ما تشوف لها خدمات ما تشوف لها اشياء يعني
على الاقل على مستوى الافراد
تفاجات بعدها انه مع موجه شركات التقنيه
الماليه بدل البنك العربي دائما اشوفه
يطلع ويتصدر في المشهد هذا
الى فتره قريبه قبل عده سنوات احتاج خدمات
بنكيه استخدمها لاحد اجماع وانا في عمري
ما احد الشركات وكل ما سالت شركه تقنيه
ماليه عن هالخدمه
لكن الطريق اللي قدمته فيها
او التوثيق حق الحلول التقنيه اللي عندكم
نظيفه جدا وسهله ومرتبه الثانيه تعاملت
معها كانوا يعطونك حلول مستورده مثلا من
الهند من الاماكن ثانيه
ويعطونك تعرف
مستندات 700 صفحه تقدر تقرا فيها وتضيع
وما ادري شو سالفه الهندي اللي طور وتحوس
فيهم يعني فتره طويله مع البنك العربي
عشان بس افعل خدمه
الحسابات البنكيه الافتراضيه اللي بنشرحها
بعد شوي طلعنا ثلاثه اسابيع سويناهم طلعنا
فيها لايف ونمور تمام فيها ولسه ما
نختبرها ونشتغل عليها او على الاقل في
التجربه اللي مريت فيها فكانت جميله جدا
صراحه
ابي اعرف سر
تفوقكم على البنوك الاخرى من هالناحيه
لانه في اجماع كامل على تميزكم في تقديم
الخدمه سواء من ناحيه التعامل مع الشركات
او على المستوى التقني ايضا في في
المحتويات اللي تقدمونها المشكله دائما
نبلش في المسرح التقنيه
في المستندات اللي تقدمونها اللي ترشد
الناس للتطوير او في التقنيه نفسها فهو
خليكم تميزون الثانيه طيب ابي ارجع شوي بس
انت قلت ان احنا او الصوره النمطيه عننا
سابقا كانت بالنسبه لك كاننا غائبين محنا
موجودين على مستوى كيفيه الافراد مرتبطين
اكثر بالتقاعد وهذه نقطه لازم نوقف عندها
شوي صحيح احنا مرتبطين بالتقاعد الى فتره
قريبه وبالنسبه لنا يعني ما هو يعني ما هو
بكلام دعايه او شيء لكن اعتقد ان
المنظومه اللي تقدر تقدم خدمات للمتقاعدين
وخدماتي الى ناس يعني خدموا البلد في فتره
معينه
وتقاعد وبعدها هي منظومه قادره على تقديم
الخدمات للجميع الشرائح المجتمع بدون
استثناء لان اذا احنا اخذناها على مستوى
كبار السن التعامل معهم يحتاج
نوع من التعامل مختلف اذا انت طبقت على
شرائح مختلفه وشرائح اخرى بتنجح فيه بشكل
كبير
فالمتقاعدين بالنسبه لنا بركه
كبنك فخورين بان احنا في يوم من الايام
كنا البنك البنك المتقاعدين الوحيد الان
الامور مفت
من الطريقه التقليديه تحاكي وتناسب
المستقبل لها احنا يعني من فتره
قديمه جدا عندنا حلول مصرفيه متميزه جدا
والفضل يرجع الى
مجموعه من الزملاء كانوا سباقين في هذا
الشيء يعني كنا نروح للشركات او نروح
للقطاعات الحكوميه وما نقدم بس خدمات
ماليه نقدم خدمات ماليه وخدمات تقنيه معها
بحيث ان احنا يكون الحل متكامل
طبعا اول يمكن محفظه الكترونيه موجوده في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كانت من 2010 في
البنك العربي مع احد الجهات ما اقدر اذكر
اسمه بس محفظه الكترونيه من 2010 وما زالت
الى اليوم محفظه الكترونيه تستخدم لاغراض
خاصه مع احد الجهات هذا كان حل
ما لي تقني مقدم البنك العربي
هذه التجربه نمت معنا يمكن اتذكر في يمكن
2015 كان الصندوق العقاري وقتها كان بحاجه
الى عمليه الربط اللي بعدها نمت محفظه
الاقراض وكان فيه توسع في اغراض الاغراض
السكني للمواطنين
كان اول بنك يربط مع الصندوق العقاري كان
البنك العربي
واتذكر وقتها كانت عباره عن قطاع الاعمال
عندنا
يزور قطاع التقنيه ويقول احنا محتاجينكم
تروحون معنا الى الصندوق العقاري هم
محتاجين شيء احنا ما نعرفه احنا نعرف
البزنس انتم تعالوا معنا هناك فكنا نروح
ونشوف ايش هم مش محتاجين وكانت عباره عن
ربط تقني لتسهيل عمليه المنح او او حقوق
الاحقيه
المواطنين بالقروض العقاريه ومنحهم قروض
عقاريه يمكن مو واضح بالنسبه للمستمع انه
هذه فرص متوفره للجميع البنوك
لنفس المشرع ويمكن ضخامه العمل نفسها
والمسؤوليات خلينا نقول لاداره التطوير
واداره حل التقنيه البنكيه فاوش اللي
تعتقد خلاكم تميزون على الاخرين في حلول
التقنيه الماليه مع شركات الرغبه في
التميز والمنافسه يعني عندنا معقوله بس
هذا الشيء
شوف انت اليوم
البنوك تقريبا خدماتها الماليه وحدها وش
يميز بنك عن الاخر هو جوده الخدمه
وطريقه عرضها وايصالها الى
العميل لو تجي الاقراض موجود فيك البنك
الحسابات الجاريه موجوده في البنك
الموبايل بانكينج او ال ال
الاونلاين بانك موجود في كل بنك اللي يفرق
عميل بنك عن اخر هو جوده خدمته
انا كيف اطور جوده خدمتي اذا انا قدمت مع
حلول شامله حلول تكون متكامله بحيث ان
العميل يكون مرتاح وهو متعامل مع البنك
هذا ما يحتاج يروح الى بنك اخر هذه احد
الاشياء الرئيسيه اللي خلتنا نتميز في
دافع اخر يمكن بدون مجامله الى احد بس كان
في دافع تنافسي داخل البلد
جيراننا الجوازات كنا نستغرب يعني حنا في
فتره من الفترات كان الشارع يتسكر من
الجوازات فجاه ما عاد في احد مو معقول انه
قطاع حكومي الجوازات السعوديه
يعني تتحول الى الاونلاين والمعاملات
الالكترونيه واحنا في القطاع البنكي ما
زلنا متاخرين فيها فكانوا يدافع لنا كبير
ان احنا يعني نتعلم من تجربتهم ونحاول
نحكي تجربتهم وكنا على المستوى التقني
يعني كنا نقول مو معقول ان الناس اللي في
الجوازه او في القطاع الحكومي يصيرون اسرع
مننا احنا لازم نكون بنفس السرعه اللي
معهم فطلع مجموعه مجموعه الحلول اللي اللي
يمكن اليوم تغيير يعني نحاول ان احنا
نقدمها الى العملاء ونحاول ان احنا نبرز
صوره البنك الى العمله نحن عندنا حلول
تقنيه حلول شامله حلول سريعه في يعني حتى
حاولنا نطلعها في شعارنا الجديد ان احنا
اوكي الناس تتكلم عن دجاجه البنك احنا
البنك احنا بنك شامل عندنا خدمات ماليه
تقنيه تخلينا نكون ديجيت البنك شعارنا
اليوم يمكن الجديد في في اكثر من رساله
اولها ان احنا البنك ثانيها ان احنا
نتغير بسرعه يمكن الاسهم الاشياء اللي
احنا حاطينها في الشعار تدل على ان احنا
بدايه الشركات التقنيه وتقنيه الماليه
عفوا كان في
الكلام هذا يطلع انه البنوك خلاص
لكن بيبدا يصير دورها كانها دور المطبخ
اللي هي تقدم الخدمات في الخلف والشركات
التقني الماليه هي اللي تصدر مشهد وتصير
تتعامل مع المستفيدين طبعا تغير الموضوع
هذا تصحى وتقدم الخدمات بشكل مباشر بس هل
تشوف هذا الشيء
منطقي
يعني بهالشكل مع شركات التقنيه الماليه
على المستوى الشخصي نعم انا اشوف المستقبل
بالشكل هذا
[موسيقى]
قليله يمكن ما حد يشوفها بين البنوك
احنا احنا نشوف العكس مع الفندق نسبه
الشراكه كبيره وممكن يكون في نسبه تنافس
قليله
حتى تفسيرات شخصيه طبعا الناس على ليش
البنك العربي يسوي كذا ويفسرونه بشكل
البنك العربي محتد يعني مضطر انه يمكن
تميزت فيه بنك مثلا يركز على الافراد على
سبيل المثال
والاشياء الثانيه بعطيها اولويه اقل في
بنك كذا في البنك العربي قال تدري دام
الجماعه قاموا ياكلون السوق من اكثر من
جهه خلني القى الزاويه اقدر اركز عليها
وانطلق فيها اللي يمكن البلوك الثاني
يتكبر عليها تقول ما ابغى اشتغل مع شركه
تقنيمانيه وابني فيها ما اعتقد ان هذا
قراءه صحيحه المشهد اللي اللي اللي موجود
فيه البنك العربي اليوم احنا ما زلنا
منافسين وما راح نترك المنافسه اللي احد
ثاني ونركز على قطاع واحد
ونطلب من الجميع انهم ينافسولنا في قطاع
التقنيه الماليه اذا اذا ودهم
رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي اساس
النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي نوظف
خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع في
تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه
وذكاء
[موسيقى]
قراءه يعني انا ما اقدر اتكلم عنهم ولكن
وجهه نظري انها
ما في اعتراف بدوره التقنيه الماليه تعرف
حاجه جديده
ما فيها
يمكن القطاعات اللي تغطيها التقنيه
الماليه ما تعني كثير الى البنوك اول ما
بدات التقنيه الماليه كانت في البيمنتج
وما كانت تمثل شيء كبير من البنوك وما
تشوف وما يشوفونها انها يعني تستمر او
بيكون لها يعني دعم من من حتى من الحكومه
اعتقد وجود وجود كان يتوقعون صغير يعني
يعتقدون ان المشرع ما راح يعطيهم فرصه
يعتقدون مثلا البنك المركزي ما راح يسمح
الى شركات التقنيه الماليه بس اللي حصل مع
مع رؤيه المملكه 2030 اختلف تماما التقنيه
الماليه ركيزه اساسيه من
هذا التوجه ويصير البنوك بشكل عام ولا هم
صحيح مركز ابحاث ومركز ابداع يعني بدل ما
انا اروح اسوي فكره ومنس او تتحقق انت
ممكن تساهم فيها وتدعمهم الى ما تنجح
فكرتهم وتسوي زيهم ما تسوي زيهم انا ما
اعتقد انه يعني
على المستوى الشخصي على المستوى التيم
احنا درسنا السوق اللي برا وكيف البنوك
قاعده تتعامل مع شركات التقنيه او الماليه
برا ما في يعني يمكن واحد في الميه من
البنوك واقل حتى اللي يروح يسوي زي الفندق
يفتح شركات ما يعني ممكن بنكين فقط اللي
يفتح شركه مماثله الى الفندق في بنك ما
شاء الله يعني قدم خدمات حقت خمس شركات
ناشئه في السعوديه
ان تتكلم عن بشكل عالمي يعني ولا انا
اتكلم بشكل عالمي الان انا بجيك على
السعوديه السعوديه الان السعوديه مثلا
يمكن عندنا ثلاث بنوك قاعده
بالضبط
انا على المستوى الشخصي ما افضل هذا
التوجه
افضل اني انا ادخل مستثمر مع شركات
التقنيه الماليه على المستشفى الشخصي ادخل
مستثمر واذا هم نجحوا انا ناجح معاهم بس
اني انا اسوي يعني
هم يسوونه ما اعتقد متى تعتقد كبنك انه
القرار الافضل يعني او كيف تحدد قرارك في
انك تستثمر مع الشركه وانكم تجربه نتكلم
فيها او انك تسوي شركه مماثله لها او تقدم
خدمه مماثلها
بسوي شركه واقدم خدمه مماثله لها اذا حسيت
انه انا فيه بزنس كبير بيطلع من عندي وانا
ما راح استفيد ولا في شركه تقنيه انا ممكن
ادخل معها كشريك انا هنا ممكن اروح ابني
الشركه واسويها واكون انا جزء من منظومه
التنافسيه اللي موجوده بس اذا اليوم عندي
شركه قاعده تقدم الخدمه وانا اقدر ادخل
معها مستثمر واخليها هي تقدم خدمتها انا
افضل الطريقه
اني انا يعني اعاده اختراع العجله غير
صحيح امكانياتي ومواردي وطريقه عملي
مختلفه تماما عن شركات التقنيه الماليه ما
يصلح اجي انا اليوم حقي كبنك وكبير وثقيل
وادخل وابني شركه تقنيه
بكون عائق انا لشركه التقنيه الماليه بس
لو تركت شركه التقنيه الماليه تشتغل
بطريقتها وعلى باجراءاتهم وعلى راحتهم
وانا دخلت معهم مستثمر وداعم وممكن حتى
يعني اكون جزء من الفرص اللي تتحول لهم
وبتكلم بدون ذكر اسماء عن بعض التجارب
اللي احنا نسويها على شوفها افضل نرجع الى
نقطه الشخص اللي قال لك انه هي مو مركزه
وهو يسمونها
مركز الابداع في تقديم الخدمات وهذا
المطلوب هذا اللي احنا نبغى نوصل له اليوم
اذا انا بقعد بس اسوي في النهايه بقعد
اتابع هذول الناس وش يسوون هم بيكونوا
سابقيني اصلا
وبيكونوا متقدمين علي في تقديم الخدمه بس
اذا كبر السوق اللي هم شغالين فيه ممكن
تقول اوكي انا بدخل بنفسي الحين اذا كبر
السوق وانا مالي وجود في السوق عن طريق
شركات
بروح اسويها اذا في فاليولي اكيد بس انا
في البدايه اروح اسويها ما احسها مناسبه
طبعا يختلف من بنك التاني هم كيف يشوفونها
ممكن بعض البنوك يعني عنده استراتيجيه انه
يعني يبغى
يقلل يعني يخلي البنك
البنك الاساسي او الرئيسي او الخدمات
الرئيسيه في البنك هي عصب البنك وعن طريق
شركاتها الجديده اللي هو سواها يقدم
الخدمات هذه قد تكون استراتيجيه يعني
ناجحه وما فيها يعني ما فيها ضرر بس انا
على المستوى الشخصي ما افضل
شركه تابعه للبنك بتكون اكثر رشاقه واكثر
سرعه ونفس المزايا اللي اتكلم عنها على
الشركه شايفين نظرهم طبعا مع انه يختلف
الطريقه هذه وبنطلق في السودان شفنا بنوك
سوت الحركه هذه وما ضبطت معها الى الان
اللي قاعدين نشوف السوق ما هي ضابطه تمشي
بنفس سرعه الشركات التقنيه الماليه
والشركات يحاولون يحرقون الاسعار يحاولون
بس بس على مهب مهو بزنس موديل مستمر انت
حرق الاسعار وحرب الاسعار هذا يصير في اي
مكان بس فتره معينه وبعدين الناس ما عاد
تقدر عليها اصلا ويكتمل
واعتقد ان حرق الاسعار وهذه يكون له
تشريعات تحمل التنافسيه عند الجميع وهي
موجوده بس يعني يمكن مع التقنيه الماليه
والاشياء الجديده بس تحتاج انها يعد النظر
فيها
يعني
الحفاظ على التنافسيه عندنا شيء ممتاز جدا
ويعني وله منظومه
تابعه وتحاسب عليه فما اتوقع ان لاني انا
بنك وسويت شركه واقدر احرق الاسعار عندي
او عندي
يعني راس مال كبير بيسمح لي اني انا اسوي
الشيء هذا خصوصا ان التقنيه الماليه هي زي
ما هي ركيزه من ركائز الرؤيه اليوم فما
تقدر يعني المستهدف الرؤيه في 20 30 انه
يكون عندك 525 شركه تقنيه
ما في واحد بيجي يحرق الشركات هذه لانه هو
قوي وياخذ
هل في شيء برامج اي توجيه يحثكم على
التعامل مع شريعه التقنيه الماليه ولا هو
مفتوح لكل بنكي يقرر من البنك المركزي في
توجيه من فنتك السعوديه
في اشياء الزاميه وفي اشياء اختياريه بس
دائما يحسوننا على ان احنا نتعاون معهم
دائما يستشروننا في في
الاشياء الجديده اللي تجيهم
يدعوننا دائما الى كل
يعني المناسبات اللي تخص التقنيه الماليه
ودائما يتشاورون معنا في اغلب الخدمات
يعني سواء كانت المصرفيه المفتوحه او
التقنيه الماليه بشكل عام المصرفيه مفتوحه
كيف تجربتكم ايضا انتم السباقين فيها
والله يعني التجربه يعني
ممتازه حتى الان
للناس اللي ما يعرفونها باختصار وشركات
التقنيه الماليه ان تخلي المستخدمينها
يسحبون بيانات الحساب البنكي بالكامل
ويشوفونها من خلال المنصه اخرى اقدر انا
مثلا تطبيق اداره مصاريف اشوف عمليات
الحساب حق البنك من خلال التطبيق هذا بدون
ما ادخل على هذه المرحله الاولى اللي طبقت
الان المرحله الثانيه حتصير تسوي عمليات
حصير اجمع لك حساباتك في مكان واحد فيصير
انت اذا التطبيق البنك مو بعاجبك بس انت
عميل في البنك العربي مثلا تقدر عن طريق
تطبيق الى تقنيه ماليه ثانيه تشوف حسابك
في البنك العربي تتعامل معه تشوف حسابك
بنك ثاني في التطبيق هذا يصير من حقك
كعميل انك تعطي صلاحيه الى شركه التقنيه
الماليه هذه انها تطلع على حسابك وتسحب
معلوماتك من البنك اللي انت تتعامل معه
وتطلعها لك بالطريقه اللي تناسبك وكان في
مقاومه من بعض البنوك ويمكن حتى اغلب
البنوك على الموضوع هذا لانه في قناه مهمه
بالنسبه لهم اللي ممكن يبيعوا فيها تمويل
بطاقات ايا كان للمستخدم انه يدخل عليها
بشكل شبه يومي بتروح من عندهم وبصير
العميل يستهلكها من خلال الطرف ثالث ما
راح يعني باختصار كل اللي هم العمليات ولا
راح اشوف اي شيء من الينعرض عاده في
التطبيق اللي تابع للبنك
بالنسبه لكم كيف تستفيد من انك تفتح
الحسابات اللي اخرى شوف ابجيك طبعا
المقاومه مصدرها الاول يمكن يمكن زي ما
قلت انت الكلام صحيح بس ترى فيه شيء ثاني
يعني
قبل قبل الموضوع البنوك اليوم
عندها كوست دفعتها او اتكلفه دفعتها الى
معلومات العميل اللي موجوده اليوم
طلب منا ان احنا نعطيها لشركات التقنيه
الماليه تكلفه
اللي انا عطيتها شركه التقنيه الماليه
اليوم دفعت الى شركات اخرى عشان انا اتحقق
سواء كانت
طريق خدمه يقين او عن طريق خدمه التحقق من
البريد السعودي او عن طريق الرسائل الاو
تي بي اللي احنا دفعناها ففي تكلفه نسميها
احنا تكلفه
تكلفه استحواذ على العميل لما تيجي تعطيها
كذا
مجانا كانت تسبب يعني انه وايد ليش احنا
نسوي كذا
نتفهم انه في البدايه شركات التقنيه
الماليه نحتاج ندعمهم ما يملكون التكلفه
اللي احنا بنطالبهم فيها مقابل اعطاء مثل
هذه البيانات ونرجع الى شيء جديد طلع
مؤخرا انه هذه بيانات من حق العميل اصلا
ليست لا يملكها البنك فما حمايه البيانات
وخصوصيه البيانات الخاصه بالعملاء هذه
بمعلومات يملكها العميل وليس البنك
وبالتالي انت يعني
ما تقدر تمنع احد من انه يعطي صلاحيه الى
شخص اخر مصرح لانه ياخذ هذه البنك بالحياه
هذه البنك الان ما يستفيد يعني في البدايه
بس انا ممكن اشتغل مع الشركات التقنيه
الماليه في اكثر من اكثر من من
شغله يعني على سبيل المثال شركات البيرسون
الفاينانس او
اداره اداره
الحسابات اللي هي يعطيك معلومات عن عن
حسابك لاداره المصاريف
انا اليوم عندي اطلاع على حساب عميلي في
البنك العربي فقط بكره اقدر عن طريق شركه
التقنيه الماليه اطلع على حساباتها في
البنوك الثانيه واعطيه او امنحه تمويل او
امنحه خصائص اخرى بناء على معلومات اللي
في البنوك الاخرى هي ما هي بسيئه في
المقام الاول انت ممكن توجد منها فوائد
كثيره فانا هذه احد الفوائد اني انا اليوم
بقدر عن طريق شركات التقنيه الماليه اني
اسوق خدماتي بطريقه افضل انا ممكن بكره
اعرض القروض الشخصيه حقتي او البطاقات على
منصاتهم
ممكن ابدا اعطيهم
اشاركهم في بعض
نسميها احنا
[موسيقى]
تعطيهم
المحفزات انه يجيب لي عم فهو عند العميل
الان درس العميل يقدر هو يدفع كوسته زياده
ويقدر يشيك عليه في سما يشيك عليه في
اماكن ثانيه ويعطيني عميل جاهز اني انا
اقرضه بدل ما انا اتعب
فيفي
عند بيانات طابق المواصفات
عطني اياها
بالضبط
المصرفيه المفتوحه والتقنيه الماليه بشكل
عام اذا انا يعني
طريقه رؤيتنا لها وتعاملنا معها
يعني في المقام الاول
تتلخص بانه اصلا فيه فجوه كبيره
فجوه تقنيه كبيره ما بين التجار اللي
موجودين اليوم في السوق وما بين الخدمات
الماليه المقدمه
يعني مثلا اكثر قطاع انا احسه ما زال في
فجوه كبيره قطع السيارات
لا الوكالات ولا المعارض ولا اللي يشتغلون
في السيارات
عندهم قدرات تقنيه تساعدهم في انهم يوصلون
خدماتهم الى العملاء بشكل مناسب لو جينا
شفنا اليوم تمويل السيارات مزعجه تجربه
العميل مزعجه جدا الى اي واحد انت تروح
للمعرض او الوكيل شوف السياره بعدين تروح
تدور موظف البنك بعدين تطلب من موظف البنك
يطلب منك اوراق بعدين موظف البنك يتواصل
مع الوكاله هذه هذه تجربه العميل السيئه
هذه اللي يحلها لنا هو شركات التقنيه
الماليه لانه بيكونوا متخصصين ممكن يوجد
نسميها سوق الكتروني الى السيارات
وكلا السيارات يكونون في المعارض تكون فيه
وتبدا عمليه الربط مع البنوك ومع الشركات
التمويل ومع الشركات الثانيه تكون تكون
سلسه وسهله بحيث ان المنتج الاساسي اصلا
سياره ليس قرض فانا اروح اشوف السياره
واكمل اجراءات القرض من هناك بشكل سلس
وسهل هذا شيء احنا اليوم
اعرف انه في شركات تقنيه ماليه تشتغل عليه
بس ما بعد شاف النور الى الان ففي قطاعات
كثير اليوم في السوق ما عندها القدره
التقنيه اللي تواكب متطلبات العملاء في
الوقت الحالي وجود التقنيه الماليه اليوم
بساهم في يعني سد الفجوه هذه وخلق ابداع
طرق ابداعيه في الوصول وتقديم الخدمات
للعمل
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
نشوف المستقبل لانه بيكون الخدمات البنكيه
بتوصل للناس من خلال منصات اخرى مو
بالضروره المنصات حق البنك لان المنصات
هذه تجمع كل المعلومات اللي يحتاجها البنك
وتربط ما بين العميل والبنك متخصصه حتى في
اشياء معينه يعني احنا نقعد يعني تكلمنا
عن الافراد بشكل كثير يمكن لو نتكلم على
الشركات نتكلم على
ما نجمنت او اداره السلاسل السلاسل في
قطاعات كثيره اليوم في السوق ما هي ما
فيها
يعني اداره لسلاسل الامداد بشكل منظم
ومرتبط بالخدمات الماليه هذه كلها
تخصص شركات التقنيه انها تيجي وتوجد
الحلول وترتبط عن طريق المصرفيه المفتوحه
عن طريق التقنيه الماليه بالبنوك وتقدم
حلول افضل الى الشركات لكن الحلقه على
موضوع على النقطه هذه انك تشوف الشركات
التقنيه مركزه بشكل كبير على القطاع
الافراد قطاع الاعمال تركيز كبير فيه
تعتقد الفرصه اللي موجوده هناك في فرص
كثيره يعني انا الدراسه اللي عندنا اليوم
تقول انه او منفنتك السعوديه يقول لك 30%
من شركات التقنيه الماليه اللي موجوده
اليوم في السوق السعودي في البيمنت
بالمدفوعات
25% في التمويل وكلها تختص في الافراد
وتبدا تنزل النسبه على القطاعات قطاع
الشركات ما فيه عدد ابدا
لا يكاد يذكر العدد اللي يقدم بخدمات الى
قطاع الشركات وقطاع الشركات بشكل عام سواء
كان في البنوك يمكن انت تكلمت عن تجربتك
مع بنك ثاني او انه كيف انك انت يعني
عانيت للحصول على الخدمه اعتقد
الخدمه في البنوك في شركات التقنيه
الماليه الى الان الى قطاع الشركات ما
وصلت الى الشيء اللي احنا نطمح له هلا انه
ما في سوق كبير
بس ما في طلب ولا
يعني زي ما تكون ما بعده صار لهم الدور في
في الابداع ولا انا اعتقد ان اليوم بدات
الشركات التقنيه الماليه تلمس الفرص اللي
موجوده وبدينا نشوف كم شركه تشتغل على فرص
جميله جدا وذهبيه لدرجه ان احنا احيانا
ودنا بعض الخدمات اللي نقدمها نروح
للشركات تقنيه العمليه هذه ونقدمها عن
طريقهم يعني نطلب من شركات اللي تتعامل
معنا انها تاخذ الخدمه من الشركه التقنيه
الماليه
لان الطريقه اللي هم مقدمينها بطريقه
مع ضخامه السوق بس مسحوب عليهم البنوك
بشكل عام يعني ما في ما يجي ولا ربع
اهتمام القطاع الافراد انا ما سوى دعايه
بس ما عاد احنى يعني
على الاقل الخدمات المقدمه للشركات غير
الحسابات الافتراضيه وغيرها بس قصدي مثلا
اشياء بسيطه زي اداره حساب الشركه
من فتره طويله جدا والموضوع مزري مقارنه
بالخدمات المقدمه للافراد وفي صعوبه وفي
يعني احد البنوك اللي تعاملت معها في احدى
الشركات
ما تقدر حتى تضيف ناس معك في الفريق
عليها كان في صعوبه كبيره في الموضوع هذا
ما في اساس البنوك نفسه غير مهتمه
وش السبب اللي يخلي البنوك غير مهتمه عشان
برضو
يشوف
مو بالبلوك مهم
انا بكون مهتم اذا العميل
يحتاج وطلب قطاع الشركات في البدايه ما
كان يطلب وما كان وما كان يحتاج هذه
الاشياء اليوم الشركات تغيرت طريقه عملها
يعني مع التشريعات اللي موجوده على
الشركات مع الاشياء اللي متطلب يعني
الاشياء التي تطلب من الشركات مضطرين انهم
يحطون حلول تقنيه اساسهم يطلبون عندك
بموضوع
البطاقات الشركات اللي بدات تطلع مجموعه
شركات تقنيه ماليه في الحين انه انا ابغى
اصعب شيء اقدر اصدر بطاقه وسط البطاقات
الموظفين يصرفونا في اماكن معينه او بحدود
معينه هذا طلب اذكره من متى من ظهر عشر
سنين
قال خلاص حتى تضطر انه يصدرها من خلال
البحرين على سبيل المثال لانه ما يقدر
يشتغل بهالشكل بالسعوديه فهو شو السبب انه
ما تحركوا
هنا هنا نرجع الى دور شركات التقنيه
الماليه بالنسبه للبنوك هذا شيء صغير جدا
ولا هو بالعامل الرئيسي في ان الشركه
تتعامل مع البنك هو خدمه بسيطه اضافيه
البنك يقدمها بناء على طلب الشركه
ممتاز قصدي كمثال على الطلب فقط
الطلب يعني لا هذا الطلب بسيط جدا مقارنه
بالطلبات الثانيه اللي هي اهم بالنسبه
للشركه الشركه ايش تبي تمويل تبي اسعار
تنافسيه اليسار هنا الشركه تجي للبنك ما
تجيني عشان والله البطاقه اليوم بس اليوم
اختلف الوضع اليوم لا اليوم تبي حلول
الماليه شامله ابي انا اقدر اروح اخذ منك
قرض بس اروح على الواحد يعطيني الخدمات
هذه افضل هل انت ودك كبنك انه عملك يكون
موجود في اكثر من بنك لانك ما تقدم لا
طبعا
وجود الشركات التقنيه مهمه الان هو
التمويل والاشياء الاساسيه من الشركات بر
اليوم عندي خدمات تقنيه كثيره انا اقدر
اعتمد عليها وخدمات مقدمه من من جهات
حكوميه في قطاع الافراد اكثر من قطاع
الاعمال
مؤخرا بدات قطاع بدا قطاع الاعمال ياخذ
يعني جانب من الخدمات المقدمه له يعني انا
عشان اتحقق من شركه اول ما كان عندي خدمه
عشان اتحقق من موظفين الشركه من ملاك
الشركه ما كان في خدمات اليوم في خدمات
هذه تساعدني اني انا ابدا يعني اطور حلول
تناسب الشركات وتساعدهم على على اداره
عملكم
انه بالنسبه لهم اسهل بكثير موضوع الافراد
لانه فيك جميع الخدمات اللي تساعدهم
التحقق بشكل سريع ويقدرون على طول يعطون
مقرر مثلا ويقفلون
بشكل سريعه بينما الشركات فيها شغل يدوي
اكثر صحيح فياخذ وقت طويل والى ما يتحقق
واذا يمكن زال ما يعطي قرض للشخص مثلا من
الافراد في يوم ولا يومين بيقعد اسبوعين
مع الشركه لما قفلنا الموضوع غير طبعا
الموضوع كفاله بالضبط او في اشياء ثانيه
يعني مثلا اليوم مثلا ما زالت الخدمات
تطور بس مثلا اليوم انا ما اقدر اطلع
سند لامر الى شركه الا اذا هي الاونر حقها
فرد
نتوقع ان المفروض على المستقبل يعني انا
عشان اسوي خدمه الكترونيه كامله محتاج انه
ما يكون في توقيع فيزيك على الاوراق حقه
القروض فاستبدلها
بخدمة وزاره العدل اللي هي
اسمها
ناجز او ما في توقيع الكتروني هذا التوقيع
الالكتروني اللي هو عن طريق هذا بس هذا
مقدم الى الافراد فقط الى الان شركات
اللي فيها اكثر من واحد او المؤسسه هذه
مؤسسات فرديه المؤسسات الاكبر الى الان
انا لازم اخذ يمثلها
فردت لها فرد هذه انا اقدر اعطي الشركه
فيها شركه لازم نرجع نضطر الى ان احنا
نتعامل ورقيا فيها اشوف انه فيه يعني في
تقدم في الموضوع
بطيء جدا بحكم زي ما قلت انت انه ترى
تمويل الشركات معقد جدا معقد جدا
ودراسه التمويل دراسه
الطلب نفسه معقده جدا هذا لا يعني ان احنا
ما يعني ما نتحول فيه الى الى
تمويل الالكتروني مع الافراد راح شيك عليه
شوف في تقرير سمه اموره تمام عنده راتب
انطلق بينما الشركات
في عندنا بيان تعطينا معلومات عن الشركات
زي ما قلت لك احنا عندنا مثلا التمويل
المؤسسات المتوسطه والصغيره اون لاين تقدم
اوراقك اونلاين امنحك التمويل خلال ثلاث
ايام الاوراقك مكتمله سابقا كان 14 يوم
ورق في عشرين خط تحت
نسبه التمويل اللي اليوم مع كفاله
بالتعاون مع كفاله وبدون كفاله يعني احنا
عندنا التمويل
اثنين بس مثلا اليوم اليوم حنا واحنا
نتكلم اليوم 70% من قروضنا للمنشات
المتوسطه الصغيره عن طريق البوابات فكلها
اونلاين
فالاوراق ممتازه ومكتمله وما فيها مشاكل
وماشي تمويل بشكل سلس وجميل جدا حلو
ذكرت موضوع الاستثمار في شركه تقنيه
الماليه ولكم تجربه فيها دخلت شركه اسمها
كاشي بس عن وجه الشركه هذه وشك كان سبب
دخولكم معها كمستثمر لما تكلمنا عن شركات
تقنيه الماليه قلت لك ان احنا اذا نشوف
نموذج عمل يقدم من الشركه الماليه
وهو متناسق مع توجهاتنا احنا نفضل ان
الشركه الماليه تقوم فيه وحنا نستثمر فيها
وتكمل شغلها كاشي شركه متخصصه
بتقديم خدمات ماليه للاطفال
للاطفال خلنا نقول يعني حتى ما هم
مراهقين بعد تقريبا المراهقين الى سن
خلينا نقول 18 سنه او 16 سنه 17 اي احد
يعني اي حد ما يطلع حساب ما يفتح حساب
بالضبط لا هو يقدر يفتح حساب بنكي بس انت
تحتاج خدمات اخرى معه يعني حتى يعني برامج
الرؤيه يعني اللي خاصه بالقطاع المالي
وتطوير القطاع المالي تنص على انه
نرفع الوعي المالي نرفع الثقافه الادخار
وجزء من البرامج مخصصه للصغار السن انه
نرفع ثقافه الادخار والوعي المالي عندهم
من وقت بدري كافي متخصصه بهذا الشيء احنا
متخصصين انا ما عندي قدره اني اروح الى
المدارس واسوق منتج مالي واشرح الى الصغار
واحط لهم تتوريوس او او ملفات تدريبيه
وحطلع العاب في الاب اذا كملها ياخذ نقاط
ونقاط هذا يقدر يصرفها في مكان ثاني
مو بتخصصي بحكم وجود شركه متخصصه وشركه
تقنيه
ماليه موجوده شفنا ان احنا نستثمر فيها
ونعطيهم هذا اللاين اوف بزنس يبد فيه
بطريقتهم بهذا هذه باختصار كاشي وسبب
دخولنا معهم فيها
وان شاء الله ان احنا يعني قريب يعني نطلق
الاب الخاص فيهم وبيكون يعني
الاباء عندهم قدره على التحكم في الحساب
عندهم قدره على انهم يحطون الفلوس في
الحساب وبنفس الوقت فيه يعني حتى فيه
شراكات مع قطاعات حكوميه وشبه حكوميه
ان احنا نحط محتوى في هذه التطبيقات تناسب
صغار السن من ناحيه الامور الماليه وكيف
اثراء معلوماتهم فيها
من المتقاعدين
طيب في يمكن ما توسعنا فيها شوي موضوع
الخدمات اللي حاليا متميزين فيها مع شركات
المتوسطه الصغيره يمكن من ابرزها
الحسابات الافتراضيه فكره الحسابات بس لان
الناس اللي ما مرت عليهم قبل كذا ببساطه
انا شركه عندي حساب بنكي اقدر اعطي ارقام
حسابات لعملائي بحيث يدعون فيها مبلغ بس
فعليا المبلغ هذا
ينودك في حسابي انا حساب الشركه بس من
خلال حلول التقنيه المقدمه اقدر اقول
للعميل ترى حسابك فيه مثلا عشره ريال معنا
عشره ريال هذا بحسابي بس لانه في ربط تقني
في الموضوع هذا مجرد ما يحول على الايبان
حقه تقنيا اعرف ان العميل هذا حول الايبان
هذا فقل للعميل ترى عندك عشره ريال يعني
انا مديلك فيها
وتكون هذه العشره ريال في حسابي واقدر
اسوي العمليات تلقائيا اربطها مع
السيستم عندي
فهذا مطور داخلين عندكم صح عكس بعض الملوك
يمكن تستخدم انظمه خارج يه
نجي الى تطوير سواء تطور داخليا او انظمه
خارجيه ما يفرق كثير اللي يفرق معك هو
طريقه تصميمك الى المنتج
هو مطور داخليا والسبب القرار الداخليه
احنا
في قرار اتخذناه يمكن
قبل فتره انه الاشياء اللي احنا نحتاج
فيها سرعه
وفيها خصوصيه الى الخدمه المقدمه
نبي نطورها داخليا لانه في عندنا تحكم في
العمل وسرعه في الانجاز اكثر من ان احنا
نروح من خلال شركه تطور لنا الخدمه
المطلوبه
الاشياء اللي جاهزه وما تحتاج اعاده
اختراع العجله من جديد ومعروف انها جاهزه
وهي افضل شيء موجود في السوق احنا نروح
الى الشركه ونطلب منهم انهم يعطونا
المنتج هذا ونشغله احنا يعني على سبيل
المثال يعني في اشياء لها علاقه مثلا في
لها علاقه في الالتزام مثلا
في برامج متخصصه متخصصه في غسيل الاموال
ما اروح انا اطور برنامج متخصص بقصير
الاموال الداخليه عشان والله ما اجيب شركه
لا اجيب الشركه هي متخصصه هي عارفه عندها
خبره طويله ما هي
مجال اختصاصي اصلا فاستفيد من هذه الاشياء
واستفيد من خبراتهم العالميه اروح اجيب
شركه واطلب منها انها تقدر تنفذ لي واشرف
على التنفيذ واكون انا مسؤول عن عن دعم
المنتج في الاخير الاشياء اللي فيها
خصوصيه مثل الخدمات المقدمه لشركات تقنيه
الماليه مثل التطبيق البنكي الخاص بنا
نشوف ان احنا عندنا اكثر في التغيير
الناس اللي احنا نعتمد عليهم اللي هم راس
المال البشري عندنا مبدعين بشكل كبير لما
تجي هذه الامور
لانهم يكونون قريبين من السوق قريبين من
الزملاء في قطاع الاعمال فيفهمون
متطلباتهم بشكل افضل
وعندهم قدره سريعه على التجاوب معهم هذه
تعطينا يعني فرص اكثر في السوق وفرص اكثر
مع زملائنا في قطاع الاعمال يكونون هم
مرتاحين
دخولك مع شركات فيها اجراءات طويله سواء
كان في تعيين الشركه لازم تروح اثره يعني
لازم تطرح مناقصه تختار الشركه وبعد
اختيار الشركه تدخل في مرحله العقود
وتوقيع العقود وهذه تاخذ فتره طويله ما
تعطيك
تفاعل المناسب للسوق فحددنا بعض المنتجات
قلنا احنا هذي نبغاها تكون داخليا لان
احنا نبغى نكون سريعين
مثل
الخدمات المقدمه التقنيه الماليه سواء
كانت
التطبيق البنكي تطبيق
مفتوح
من يمكن اول شارع اول شركه تقنيه تسمح لي
يقول الاسماء اول شركه تقنيه تقنيه ماليه
في المصرفيه المفتوحه طلعت
شافت النور في السعوديه كانت شركه ملاءه
وكانت مشتغله مع البنك العربي
وملاء علي قصه معهم جميله اذا اذا في وقت
قلتها بس احنا من زمان اول ناس طلعنا بس
المصرفيه مفتوحه ما يقدر احد يستفيد من
الخدمات هذه الا اذا كانت شركه تقديم
عليهم مرخصه صحيح ما اقدر اجي انا كشركه
من خارج القطاع شركه في اي واقول ابي لو
سمحت في عميل عندي
مهما سويت
طبعا هنا نرجع الى انه
دور البنك المركزي تشريعي مهم جدا لنكد
يعني اذا اعطيت اكسس على احد او اعطيته
صلاحيه انه يدخل وهو مو مصرح له
وما مر بالاجراءات اللي تضمن حمايه العميل
حمايه معلوماته وحمايه حسابها انت ممكن
تدخل في في
مشاكل
يعني كبيره جدا وتعرف مجال الاموال مجال
الخطير انك انت تدخل فيه مشاكل يبدا في
غسل الاموال تبدا في جريمه تبدا فيه يعني
يبدا يدخل يروح الى مرحل منحه خطير يعني
على على معلومات واتمنى يعني الحلقه في
معلومات ممكن ناخذها يعني خلنا نقول
الشركه التقنيه الماليه اذا
حاول يدخل على البيانات
الحساب العميل يقدر ياخذها بشكل كامل
بينما شركه غير مرخصه ممكن ياخذ اشياء
عامه ياخذ مثلا متى فتح الحساب كم متوسط
ممكن المبالغ في الحساب واذا كان المبلغ
اعلى من كذا واقل من كذا ملامح عامه تساعد
في رفع الثقه ما بين العميل والشركه
المرتبطه في الحساب البنكي ما احس والله
انا ما اقدر اتكلم عن النيابه عن البنك
المركزي
توصل الى احد انا اعتقد انها خطيره لانك
انت بتدخل في يعني انا اذا عرفت متوسط
حسابك
بعرف انك
شيء ثاني مثلا
علمني الحساب البنكي هذا تابع للشخص هذا
ولا لا
مثلا يعني اشياء بسيطه يعني بمشي معك لان
احنا ترى طالعين من مرحله احتيال مالي
كبيره فبمشي معك في هذه لو علمتك انك انت
في البنك الفلاني وبعد شوي جتك مكالمه من
محتال قال لك معك البنك الفلاني وانت
حسابك في البنك الفلاني واعطاك معلومات
خلت انت تثق ان فعلا جايك من البنك
الفلاني وبديت تفصح انت عن الهذا وارتكب
جريمه ماليه معك واحتيال مالي واخذ منك
فلوس
بروح احاسب مين بروح اتابع مين
ضروري ضروري
المنظومه الماليه تكون تحت تشريع
الاجراءات ترى يمكن في ناس
كلهم يعني اذا تحبوا الناس كلهم
يشوف التشديد
التشديد كان له يعني
له وقته ومتطلب ضروري لانه صراحه ما كان
في وعي مالي في اواعي عند العملاء في وش
المعلومات اللي ممكن تقدم ومتى البنك
بيتواصل معك شفنا حالات صراحه يعني ما
كانت يعني العميل اعطى كل شيء
منح كل شيء واكتشف بعد عشر ايام يعني قعد
10 ايام يمنح الى المحتال هذا كل شيء بعد
عشره ايام يكتشف ان حسابه فضا
البنك المركزي ما قال هذه خطا العميل حمل
حملنا احنا مسؤوليتها قال مهما كان خطا
العميل انت عندك مسؤوليه انك تحمي عميل
هذا طبعا هذا لا يعني ان احنا بنخلي يعني
بنستمر بالاجراءات المشدده بالطريقه اللي
هي موجوده فيها بس على الاقل اليوم فيه
فيه اجراءات قاعده
تدرس بحيث ان احنا مو نرجع نسهل الى
العملاء بس بنفس الوقت ما نقع في نفس
المشاكل مره اخرى فهذا جانب يخص البنك
المركزي في جانب ثاني مهم جدا فاني انا ما
اقدر اتيح بيانات العملاء
لاي شخص وبدون
ان الشخص هذا يكون خاضع الى التشريعات
البلد بطريقه صحيحه الان فيه نظام حمايه
البيانات الشخصيه صدر من مرسوم ملكي
يلزمنا ان احنا نحافظ على سريعه البيانات
فما نقدر احنا نمنحها الى اي شركه موجوده
بس لانها شركه لازم الشركه برضو هذه تكون
داخله في اجراءات نضمن برضو حتى سريه
المعلومات اللي راحت لهم
بحيث انه اذا حصل اي
اي تسريب الى هذه المعلومات والعميل تضرر
ويرغب في اللجوء الى القضاء او الى الجهات
المسؤوله لاخذ حقها يعرف ان ياخذ حقه
يعني البنك المركزي والجهات المشرع الثاني
معها كل الحق من وجهه نظري في انها تطلب
هذه الاجراءات
انا على المستوى الشخصي ضد انها تكون
مفتوحه الى اي احد حتى لو تم تطبيق
الاجراءات هذه بدون ما شركه تتحول الى
شركه تقنيه ماليه مرخصه هذا شيء عادي يرجع
للمشرع اذا طبق الاجراءات وفيه جهه
تشريعيه تسمح له سواء كانت البنك المركزي
او واحد ثاني
حتى تسوي فيها الاجراءات اعرف عميلك
بتكلفه اقل بكثير يعني بدل ما اخلي العميل
يجي عندي على سبيل المثنى شركه تقنيه
ماليه واحاول تحقق منه من اكثر من جهه
اتحقق منه بس في عن طريق حساب البنك خلاص
انا اعرف انه هذا اذا عنده داخل حساب
البنكي فانا اعرف ما اقدر اثق فيه ان هذا
العميل كيف شلون بدون ما نشوف يعني هل
تطلع
اكبر في مجال اليوم في الساند بوكس ان
احنا نسوي كل شيء بدون ما يكون عندك
الرخصه انت الساند بوكس موجود عشان تجرب
كل هذه الاشياء وممكن ما يتطلب منك رخصه
طبعا القرار راجع البنك المركزي فيها بس
الساند بوكس اليوم موجود او
تجريبيه موجود للتجربه هذه الافكار كلها
فما اعتقد انه فيه مشكله في التجربه
والبنك المركزي يرحب في التجربه واحيانا
يعطيك حتى
لما فتره معينه مع مع اكسس معين ويطالبك
في تقارير عشان هو يراجع ويبدا يخلق
تشريعات تناسب الموضوع وهو خلق الى هذا
الشيء يعني وجد البيئه التجريبيه اللي
موجوده وجدت الى هذه الافكار ما اختم معك
لو تعطيني نبذه بس عن كيف تغير القطاع
البنكي من خلنا نقول من يوم ما بدات تشتغل
مع البنك الى اليوم وايضا ناخذ يعني رايك
على توجه مستقبل خاصه مع دخول
البنوك الرقميه شوف القطاع البنكي مثل كل
القطاعات اللي موجوده اليوم في السوق في
تغير كبير حصل خلال يعني بعطيها العشرين
سنه اللي مضت يعني اتذكر انه عدد الناس
اللي يزورون الفروع عندنا عدد العمليات
المنفذه عن طريق الفروع كان رقم مهول
اليوم نتكلم على
نسبه ضئيله جدا ما تمثل يمكن 95% من
عملياتنا الماليه تنفذ عن طريق الاونلاين
والتطبيقات
5% فقط لتنفذ عن طريق الفروع فهذا تغير
روش السبب انه ما زال في التحول الرقمي
والتقني اللي حصل والثوره التقنيه اللي
صارت في الخدمات ووعي العملاء الى الى
ركز على اوعي العملاء ووعي العملاء الى
وثقتهم في الخدمات التقنيه المقدمه
ليش اقول وعى العملاء وثقتهم عندنا امثله
مثلا في بعض الانواع من القروض اليوم
العميل يجينا في الاون لاين يقدم يشوف كم
يطلع له بعدين يكنسل ويجي يزور الفرع تكلم
العميل تقول له ليش يعني ليش ما كملت
والله مبلغ كبير انا ماني مستحيل مستحيل
الثقافه الهذا والثقه هذه ترجع للثقه ترى
الثقه والثقافه الهادي ما زالت في بعض
الاشياء لا يحس انه لازم يجي للفرع ويشوف
موظف قدامه يتعامل معه ويساله يمكن اكتر
من سؤال وهذه احنا قاعدين نحاول نقدم لها
حلول تكون يعني تقنيه تساعد في انك انت
يعني تسد الفجوه هذه بس هذا تغير كبير
يعني
العملاء اللي كانوا اول ما عندهم كنا اول
نعاني ان احنا نحاول نقول للعميل
سجل اونلاين حط لك يعني حط لك يوزر
اونلاين استخدم حساب خدماتنا اونلاين كان
فيها صعوبه اليوم تتكلم على
ارتفاع نسبه تقريبا اربعين في الميه من
العام الى السنه هذه في عدد الناس اللي
يشتركون عندنا في الاون لاين
فيه توجه كبير الى هذا وتلاحظ الضغط يجينا
من
الفيدباك اللي يجي من العملاء يعني راي
العميل في الخدمه المقدمه لما يجي يتكلم
على شيء يجيك احيانا فيدباك يعني يخليك
انت تغير تطبيقك بسبب العميل هذا لانه
فعلا
صارت له يعني صار له مشكله في في
نحو الخدمات الرقميه جدا قطاع الاعمال
قطاع الاعمال
اشوف انه يعني من وجهه نظرنا او من من من
البنك من عندنا الحلول الماليه متقدمه جدا
تطورت طبعا انا اعطيتك انه احنا من 2010
واحنا نقدم حلول الماليه
وهذه متطوره معنا وقعدت يعني
تتطور بشكل اكثر واسرع الان
يظل قطاع الشركات
يعني
متطور يعني يتطور لكن بشكل بطيء جدا
مقارنه بغيرها من القطاعات وهذا ارجع يعني
ممكن تكون مقصره فيه شوي بس برضو حتى
المنظومه كامله ما زالت الى الان ما هي
جاهزه انها ترتقي بالقطاع بالشكل اللي
ارتقى فيه قطاع الافراد
ولكن وش اللي ناقص في المنظومه
الترابط والتكامل يعني ما زالت الان
ونشوفها قاعده تتحلل الامور بشكل يعني ما
زالت في اشياء خدمات كثير
اللي هي تساعدك على انك انت
تقدم خدمه موثوقه الى العميل ما هي موجوده
سواء كانت معلومات الشركات
الموافقات حقت الشركات
التوقع الالكترونيه للشركات الى اخره هذه
كلها ما زالت غير موجوده يعني لما نيجي
نتكلم على
حتى يعني احيانا الشركه تقول لك انا ابي
تمويل لان عندي المشروع الفلاني او عندي
هذه كلها بعض فانا ما اقدر اقدم خدمات
متكامله اذا ما في منصات اليوم قاعده تقدم
كل هذه الخدمات وانا اقدر اوصلها بشكل
سريع واغير نموذج العمل واطوره هذه متعطله
حاليا ان ما في شركات تخدمها ولا ما في
تشريع ممكن يخدم يمكن الشركات هذه تخدم
الله انا ما اعتقد ان عندنا قصور في
التشريعات يعني ما اعتقد
يعني التشريعات سباقه انا من وجهه نظري
يعني 20 سنه في القطاع المشرع وما اتكلم
بس عن بنك المركزي بس بركز على البنك
المركزي ترى سباق يعني البنك المركزي
يعني اليوم مدى على سبيل المثال من البنك
المركزي من في اليوم في العالم عنده بطاقه
خاصه فيه تستخدم داخل البلد ترى قليل جدا
الكل يعتمد على شركات اخرى بس احنا عندنا
لوك البراند مستخدم وقصه نجاح كبيره
البنك المركزي كان سباق فيها
يعني في امثله كثير البنك المركزي كان
يدعونه كابنوك ويطالبنا ان احنا
نشارك
ونستثمر في افكار بعضها نجح بعضها ما نجح
يعني سداد ايضا ترى قصه نجاح عظيمه يعني
انا اقولها كنا نروح نزور نشوف مؤتمرات
خارج البلد يعني قبل يعني شوف احنا الحين
نبغى نتطور اكثر بس او يعني على وقتنا اول
على وقت سداد كان كنا نروح نشوفهم يقول
هذول يتكلمون عنه حنا وينهم وين يعني من
ناحيه الخدمات المقدمه من البنك المركزي
ترى كان سباق
الان نحتاج الى قفزات اكبر واكبر وحلو
بصراحه في اشياء زي مدى انجاز عظيم جدا في
اشياء اخرى مثلا الشخصيه زي سريع مثلا ما
اعتقد انه تنفذ بطريقه يعني الامثل خلنا
نقول
ما ادري هل المشكله من طبعا تغير اسمه
الان سريع هو
الحوالات الفوريه اللي قاعده تصير انا
اتوقع هذا تغيير
يتماشى مع اللي انت تقوله اذا سريع القديم
كان معقد وصعب وكذا فسريع الجديد ترى
مختلف تماما
اللي هو اللي سموه اي بي اس اللي هو
الحوالات الفوريه اللي تستخدم رقم جوالك
المعرفات والامور هذه المتعلقه فيها معقده
ما هي زي مثلا تكلم عن زي شركه تقنيه
الماليه اللي خلاص حط رقم جوالك في رقم
جوال تربطه كل بنك له رقم جوال مختلف
وبعدين في حد لازم تروح بعض البنوك يعطيك
الحد كامل البدايه وبعضهم لا يعطيك صفر
ولازم تروح ترفع الحد ترى هذه لها علاقه
بالاحتيال اول اول كانت محطوطه بشكل صحيح
بس بعد الاحتيال المالي تغيرت بس ارجع الى
انك انت عمليه الربط هذه كلها اشياء بسيطه
تتغير مع الوقت لكن احيانا انت مجبر على
الاشياء انا ما اعرف رقم جوالك في اي بنك
انت ممكن عندك اكثر من رقم مرتبط بموضوع
الاحتيال انه ما اعلمك لازم اخذ منك
معلومات شوي تكون يعني اكثر من معلومه
عشان اتاكد انك
بس انا اعتقد ان هذا تحول جيد الانفتاح
اليوم على شركات التقنيه ايضا تحول جيد
فارجع الى انه المشرع
قد يكون عنده احيانا قصور قد يكون هذا اي
عمل طبيعي ولكنه سباق دائما في انه يحاول
انه يعني يوجد التشريعات المناسبه للخدمات
المطلوبه او اللي يحتاجها دخول البنوك
الرقميه الحين في اكثر من بنك رقمي يتم
التصريح له وانت تقول انه الحين العربي او
ان بي عشان
بنك رقمي ايضا
الفرق
الاساسي والجوهري من وجود كل هالبنوك هذه
هو الخدمه المقدمه للعميل اعتقد ان كل هذه
البنوك الموجوده ستساهم في اثراء تجربه
العميل وتقديم خدمات ماليه رائعه الى
العملاء في النهايه في العالم كلها واحد
تقدم خدماتها يعني
مرور لست يقول له نفس الخدمات يفرق العميل
كيف انت تقدم الخدمه للعميل وجوده الخدمه
واستمراريه الخدمه للعميل وتنوعها وشمولها
يعني
هذا اللي يفرق اذا احنا نتكلم على الاي
بيجيتال بنك صحيح احنا من سنتين يعني يمكن
بدينا نغير الهويه حقتنا نتماشى مع
المتطلبات الحاليه بقياده ابو عبد الله
الله يمسيك بالخير استاذ عبيد الرشيد
واللي ضغطنا كثير يعني سنتين كانت سنتين
عن عشرين سنه ترى يعني صحيح اني انا عمري
20 سنه او 19 سنه في البنك بس السنتين
الاخيره كانت شيء مختلف تماما
يعني علينا ضغط كبير ان احنا نحاول نواكب
المجريات السوق نحاول نقدم خدمه تليق
باسمناء وتليق بتطلعاتنا اللي احنا
رسمناها في تغيير هويتنا
الهويه القديمه ما كانت ماشيه مع جوده
الخدمه ههه الهويه القديمه لها وقتها ولها
زمانها زمن جديد
يعني شوف
جوده الخدمه ترى يعني
كل شيء كل شركات تمر باحيانا بمراحل مراحل
ما كنا سيئين بس ما كنا افضل ناس اليوم
علينا ضغط كبير ان احنا نكون الافضل اذا
لا لا
كان مرتبط اكثر بالصوره نمطيه للبنك اكثر
من الواقع صحيح صحيح وعشان كذا احنا نحاول
الحين يعني نغير
الهويه هو شيء طبيعي في الشركات كل ما
تغيرت يعني استراتيجيه الشركه تغيرت
التوجهات الشركات تحاول ترسل العملاء
الرساله هذه عن طريق تغيير هويتها وتغيير
خدماتها يعني الموضوع تغيير هويه يجب ان
يتمشى تغيير الهويه مع خدمات المقدمه
للعملاء وهذا الضغط اللي قاعد يصير علينا
اليوم بشكل كبير يعني زملاء الله يعطيهم
العافيه كلهم جميعا
نرجع ونقول لهم راس المال البشري هم اللي
وراء كل هذه يعني الاشياء اللي تشوفونها
بشكل جميل والاشياء اللي تشوفونها ان شاء
الله نحنا بنعدلها بس احنا المسؤولين عنها
ههه الله يعطيك العافيه عبد العزيز
استمتعت اليوم باللقائك الله يرضى عليك
يطول بعمرك شكرا انا استمتعت واذا اذا في
وقت انا ودي اشكر شركه ثمانيه ممثله
بسوالف بزنس
والبرامج الاخرى الزميله لكم يعني قاعدين
تجربتنا وهذا شيء احنا كنا نفتقده انا سرد
القصه او الستوري تولينج موجود وكالتشر
موجود في يعني في اماكن خارج السعوديه
المهم موجود بشكل مكثف في السعوديه في
السابق وكنا نفتقد الى هذه الخبرات انها
تنقل يعني كتاب حياه في الاداره الى
الوزير غازي القصيبي الله يرحمه ثري جدا
انا بالنسبه لي انا تعلمت منه كثير كنت
وفي اكثر من كتاب مثله بس عدد الكتب قليل
عدد الناس اللي عندها استعداد تسوي كتاب
قليله والعصر اليوم تغير البرامج هذه جدا
رائعه
نسمعها مع زحمه الرياض
بالطريق نسمعها واحنا في النادي نسمعها
وحنا نتمرن يعني شاكر لكم والحقيقه انها
يعني شيء جدا عظيم اتمنى انكم تستمرون
عليه والله الله يعطيك العافيه
ايضا على سعه صدرك وعلى ظهوركم معنا في
البرنامج سواء لك او البنك لانه فعلا يعني
من احد الصعوبات نواجهها
بجميع البرامج في ثمانيه نحصل على فرص
اللقاء مع الجهات لانه عاده او جهات رسميه
سواء بدونك سواء كانت حكوميه لانه دائما
في ذاك الجانب التخوف من ظهور الاعلاميين
لا اخاف سؤال ما اعرف لو اخاف يصير كذا
اخاف اطلع بشكل سيء قليل جدا جهات اللي
فعلا مستعد تطلع وتكلم وتفيد الناس حيث
الناس يكون عندهم الطلاء على وش يصير في
السوق وايش الفرص اللي موجوده وايش
الخدمات اللي ممكن نستفيد منها فشكرا لك
الله يعافيك وان شاء الله نحن نكون مفيدين
واثرينا اللقاء وان شاء الله المستمعين
والمشاهدين تستفيدون ما قصرت شكرا شكرا
هلا والله قبل ما تقفل الحلقه اتمنى اذا
عجبتك تشاركها مع لحولك وتقيمها بتقييم
ايجابي سواء في اليوتيوب او في ايتونز
واذا كان عندكم ملاحظات عنها
سواء على ايميل البرنامج سوالف ثمانيه او
حتى على حسابي في تويتر شكرا لمتابعتكم
وشكرا لعبد الملك ال سعيد في اعداد الحلقه
ياسر الغانم في اداره التصوير بالاضاءه
غالب محمد ومساعده الياسر في الاخراج
الابداعي وهاب موسى في الاخراج الفني مسجد
القرشي والهندسه الصوتيه عبد العزيز المزي
في التحرير في التجهيز عبد المجيد عمر عبد
الله بن الفقيه محمد عبد العزيز او في
الانتاج التنفيذي رزان دهيثم هذا
منتجات شركه 8 للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]